elles ont juste changé de lieu les
presses dont certaines pèsent plus d'une
tonne et autres machines à gravé ont
retrouvé leurs activités ainsi que la
quarantaine d'adhérents l'association
artgvure a pris possession de ces
nouveaux locaux de 100 m Carr c'est
super même s'ils sont plus petits que ce
que nous avions mais du coup on a
optimisé tous ces ces mètres carrés et
on trouve finalement on s'y sent bien on
trouve que que ça c'est très convivial
et
on arrive à on a moins d'espace entre
les les différents postes de travail
mais c'est tout à fait suffisant fondé
il y a 41 ans l'association était
jusqu'à présent à hlencour la raison de
son déménagement les travaux de la zone
artisanale des quatre arbres son point
de chute le centre commercial du village
aquanière j'ai considéré que l'activité
d'art gravure était une activité
importante c'est un véritable patrimoine
un patrimoine immatériel avec ses
adhérents qui sont des artistes et un
patrimoine matériel avec ce que vous
voyez ici c'est-à-dire l'ensemble des
presse c'est une fierté pour moi parce
que c'est une association qui s'inscrit
dans l'histoire et moi je suis prof
d'histoire donc quelque part ça me
touche prochain rendez-vous de
l'association le marché de Noël de la
ville de coignère et les portes ouvertes
en décembre
art gravure peut maintenant graver un
nouveau chapitre de son
histoire